okay everybody now that Avengers
infinity war is out in the world the
biggest question on everybody's minds is
what now
how will the story continue to play out
in adventures for which by the way is
scheduled to come out a year from now
may 3rd 2019 let's go to sleep we're
gonna actually get into some predictions
for Avengers 4 but in order to do that
yeah we're gonna have to talk about this
movie's ending so if you haven't seen
infinity war yet yeah spoilers ahead
just pause this video and then meet us
back here in the future okay cool yeah
all right
nanos actually going through with his
plan to wipe out half the universe
Kahless one of the bleakest endings and
cliffhangers that we've ever seen in a
movie ever I think so let's recap the
death toll for all of you first
characters we saw fully die and Infinity
Ward not just fade away but like not
have a pulse even Loki Heimdall Gamora
and vision yikes
and then there was the characters that
were caught in Thanos's like snap wave
you know fading away into dust in the
film's final mats your snap snap okay so
these are the fader er where's Black
Panther the Spider Man Scarlet Witch
Bucky the Winter Soldier Doctor Strange
Falcon star-lord Peter quill Drax Groot
and mantis along with Nick Fury and
Maria hill in the post-credits scene but
now the survivors as we know them right
now are Iron Man Captain America Thor
Bruce Banner
Black Widow war machine nebula rocket
Okoye in Baku now we're not sure about
Sheree and Wong but we didn't see them
fade away so I'm guessing they're okay
hopefully Hawkeye and ant-man were with
their families during this whole mess
our Scott was on house arrest as war
machine said the wasp is probably still
around as well she'll be in the movie
with Scott Lang and as we saw a movie a
set before the events of that's what
we've all been theorizing because that
would make could you imagine we also saw
in the post-credit final image
Captain Marvel Carol Danvers will be
joining the paper yeah and check out our
post credit scene breakdown for all that
info and of course Thanos the mad Titan
was the victor in this battle but you
know what not the war I know it's early
but let's discuss some predictions of
how the surviving team could avenge the
Fallen in Avengers 4 Oh first stop real
quick before we even dive into specifics
I feel like we can need to divide it
like there's only a couple of categories
we could even look at four possibilities
like I'll throw out right away obviously
it's like okay a lot of you were time
out time travel that's a category that
could be it happening - maybe like using
the time stone to rewind for a little
bit where our time travel options some
power involving the mine stone seems
like the the first go-to idea right
because time time stone what I said time
stone yeah yeah thank you the in the
comics the Infinity Gauntlet comics
that's essentially how it works there's
a character who gets a hold of the
gauntlet and uses it to basically rewind
the clock a day without spoiler spoiling
the comic series I'll say that Adam
warlock the entirety of the rest of this
I think is based on him coming into play
and changing everything that happens
what's cool is I think it's not gonna go
that way because that character has
barely been touched on and he's tough
he's like space Jesus it's honestly I
think in this movie slate we they would
have had to been another movie to
introduce that character so I don't
think it's gonna go that Adam warlock
but so the time stone is one way to go
back in time but it does it does talk
about maybe essentially it's going and
getting it from Thanos essentially and
taking the gauntlet back something like
that also throw out there the
possibility of dealing with an eternal
like Chronos in the way that it
Dormammu kind of can be reasoned with a
little bit in Doctor Strange like maybe
it could be like hey don't you have you
don't you the embodiment of time can't
you I think time travel has some
possibilities but in terms of the ones
we've actually seen established it's
really a time stone right like that's
kind of it seems that's one way you can
do
I think the theory that usually whenever
they go open began stand-ups in the
comic he usually is his own worst enemy
and you can kind of get a hint of that
and this is that he maybe regrets part
of what he did yeah he does smile at the
end just say so maybe he's okay with
what he did but I think there's gonna
come into play maybe a discussion
between Thanos and one of the Avengers
probably Tony because it's his MCU
where they there is something there's
reasoning with Thanos and I think there
might be an outside threat because right
now we don't know where the stones are
because they're not with it from what I
remember wasn't wearing the gauntlet
yeah so he could still have it or they
they you sometimes just separate out and
they go it looks like I got it crumble
crumble because it's it's a lot of
effort and it's the the gauntlet itself
is not this amazing thing good thing it
was just forged we knew I was created by
butchering list which was cool that yeah
it was but I I think to get a good arc
for Thanos to really kind of round this
out is that he's the one who fixes it is
that he backwards which is impossible
yeah but that can't you in the middle of
reality backwards yeah but I think it's
that you're gonna get kind of a fake out
where Tony Stark and the Avengers maybe
they get the stones get kind of shot
through time or shot through the
universe so our new kind of nerfed team
has to figure out how to get them back
together and they do and maybe there's
an outside threat like I was saying that
could be a threat here that's not
banished because there's plenty of other
people that do use these all the time
it's a fun little activity people do but
I think Tony Stark's gonna maybe be up
there too like this is me like this is
I've messed up with Ultron I'm kind of
responsible in a way for the events of
the first Avengers movie because that
was his tower that opened the portal and
heard New York civil wars kind of his
fault so maybe he could have almost a
Redemption arc in that movie and the
last second Thanos Epson he does it and
he gets to live happily ever after in
the soul stone or in an afterlife and
most of the universe gets back to normal
yeah I think you're on to something I
think they're whatever the solution with
Thanos is the way this character was
drawn out in this movie it seems like
soft powers
gonna be the way end of like the guys
already having a couple doubts like he's
not just like a crazy maniacal villain
he has he reasons with himself on
whether or not this is the right
decision to make and yeah there was that
smile at the end of the movie but it
seems like this guy could be reasoned
with in the way that dr. strange reason
with Dormammu so for those of you
keeping track on our chalkboard that's
invisible or we got time-travel options
then we have getting into Thanos his
head yeah yeah like some entry college
level psychology
I put separately you kind of touched on
it but I think just getting whole a hold
of the gauntlet and somebody else doing
it that to me is a whole category of
possibilities because I think it'd be so
cool to see who I mean in the comic
there's a lot of talk who's worthy of
wielding the gauntlet you know it's not
exactly the same as it can't be held by
someone I someone else could be able to
hold it but who should hold the gun it's
a really cool if that if we were to go
with that it you've got your main three
Thor cap and Iron Man and while this is
like Iron Man's universe built around
him so it would kind of make sense way
to use it you also have two other people
that are worthy of wielding weapons of
that much power so it could it could
come down to a very interesting scene
maybe they all use it together because
sometimes you need more than one person
to like wield that much power or a
character who's an even greater threat
than Thanos takes it over to use to use
it for other purposes Stannis to switch
sides yeah in the comics a lot of the
characters they've been translated to
different characters and in the film but
the characters that are at Thanos his
side actually a lot of them have their
own sights on the gauntlet yeah yeah
there's also the idea of like rather
than I'm stone the reality stone zipping
into other realities where maybe these
characters are still alive I'm gonna put
that up on a different category yeah
because I think that's yeah alternate
realities and alternate dimensions and
they're I'm gonna give you my darkest
theory Oh darkest timeline yeah it is it
is a Dan Harmon reference actually I
think it's there is a solution here it's
dark it's a Rick and Morty asks solution
they go to a timeline where was the
exact other half very people they were
killed and that's courage
and technically they get everyone back
but we don't lose the fact that everyone
still did turn to ash yeah that's so we
still a bit to that kids still super dad
but but then we don't undo what this
movie did because that's one of the
hardest things I think it gonna be pull
off say it was for instance option one
up here on our list time travel when
they go mmm-hmm it's like great the
biggest movie of all time was just
undone do you feel satisfied by it
it would feel a little simple would be a
bit like we flew through a giant plot
hole and we save the movie you know but
you're dealing with a crazy plot device
that can do anything so it sure but so
so let's make it matter that we did that
instead of like we can just see I'm not
a huge fan of the fact that they they
won they set back time a little bit
because I think like oh well I hope that
thing comes around in the next movie
when something bad happens and you know
why don't we go fix some of the other
movies too and come on this guy still
can barely walk yeah I thought the show
Rick and Morty intentionally never
touches on time travel like there's a
box on and then the shelf in the back of
the garage it says time-travel stuff as
an in-joke that they never like then
never do time travel even though that
the show's characters are based on doc
and Marty from Back to the Future or
like a really gross parody version of
that they chose to only explore
different realities because that opens
the world up and it avoids some of those
complicated plot holes that you can fall
into with time travel I think using
different realities would be potentially
a far more interesting way to go in this
finale
far more on it would be a whole other
way to address the fact that we can't
deny that we've seen these characters
dressed in their previous costumes
behind the scenes from from Avengers 1
if it's like okay well maybe they
actually go get them from a different
timeline and and in a different moment
in a different timeline or something
like that without having to go back to
their own ones yeah I'm very excited for
Avengers 4 I think it's gonna be crazy
and it's gonna be fun I think they were
so restrictive on what they were able to
do with the story by having so many
characters
and I think by denting the herd down to
just like the bare essentials you may
get a story that goes in a lot of
different crazier places now that we're
so prepped from all these other MCU
movies doing interesting bold choices
like now that you've killed off half the
characters you kind of open yourself up
to do whatever you want almost in a way
well we'll be making more videos about
this we have a lot to explore a lot to
talk about a lot of theories we're gonna
be looking to be re watching a penny
more over and over again looking for
different clues let us know what you
think in the comments below remember to
subscribe to new rock stars for all of
our coverage on infinity to where it's
gonna be like dominating everything we
talked about we're very excited yeah to
hear what you guys think and to share
our theories with you